un niveau de suivi
maurice lot de chanel je mange un
caramel en écoutant la pluie que tu fais
sous la douche
toute approche à double de mousseux doba
ou devant ton cacao en sifflotant est
venue d'un film de lelouch
ce sont les sens de la vie
le 6ème me dit le cfi je me remets le
rouge qui est du mans le warrant et
j'accroche meba en regardant l'impasse
sur laquelle je de vous
et de ventes ont reflué qui se brossent
les dents à la menthe jusqu'en que c'est
bien la dernière fois qu avec toi
bouchons se sont eux cinq sens de la vie
le sixième est maudit 206 ni petit matin
pâle à des odeurs d'essence amèrement je
pense que cette nuit nous avons un sac à
mon sens il faudrait être aveugle pour
rien sentir du tout la rupture un goût
spécial
on entendrait nous survoler des mouches
ce sont les scènes sont le 6
ce